[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody i'm matt camp welcome in
to your
fantasy fire drill presented by the
miller lite cantenna
it's week five well things aren't really
going to plan we're gonna get to your
questions from the vr app i promise you
we'll get to those we'll talk about the
injuries the news isn't so bad but the
news is bad if you're trying to deal
with your broncos or your patriots
because that game is not happening
uh sounds like it's gonna happen next
week but both of those teams are
officially on the buy because of covin
also on tuesday we're supposed to see
the bills and the titans
the titans shut down their facility this
morning because another another positive
test came through so that game
while not cancelled is up in the air i
will tell you this obviously get your
broncos and patriots out of your lineup
because they have a buy now in week five
but your titans and bills are up in the
air if you have to make a call on any of
those players
in the next hour since we kick off in
one hour with our games for sunday
don't assume to have those players in
your lineup hopefully you can wait maybe
get more news throughout the day
but as of right now no broncos no
patriots and the titans and the bills on
tuesday
are up in the air it's gonna be that
kind of season we already know that but
let's get to the injuries a lot of this
information
is good except for what we're gonna lead
off with here although
i think you were already planning for
this because julio jones
is out today for the atlanta falcons now
i think calvin ridley who has been great
other than that awful goose egg last
week uh i think is going to be just fine
wide receiver six for me this week so
fire him up with confidence but of
course
hurts the falcon offense in general not
having julio out there now let's get to
the good news there's a lot of good news
when it comes to the injuries this week
and we get to the baltimore ravens
there's plenty of that lamar jackson's
in you fire him up with confidence
against the bengals
hollywood brown is in today let's hope
he has a better game as he takes on the
cincinnati bengals wide receiver 21 for
me
and mark andrews is in he has tight end
number four for me
you expect big things never really major
concerns there and
their opponent in this game joe mixon is
also in today you downgrade him
see you had a little patience he came
through last week maybe he dropped those
expectations a bit taking on baltimore
he's rb 14 for me
in week number five against the
baltimore ravens let's move on from that
game
get into more of these injuries here as
we said mostly good news but no desean
jackson no al shawn jeffrey this week
expect a lot of miles sanders which
we've seen enough already
a lot of zach hurts and against the
steelers maybe take a look
at greg ward as well for the eagles in
ppr formats of course all right moving
on from the eagles here
let's get into more of these injuries
early game action henry ruggs is in
i'd probably skip them i like renfro
more and i
love darren waller this week yes he is
the tight end i picked in our contest so
certainly like him even with rugs in the
lineup edwards of course
still out for your las vegas raiders
raheem moster looks like he'll be back
today this is later on of course
uh he looks like he'll be back today
demo samuel likely in the lineup there
as well
for the 49ers so i'll tell you this uh
moster is my rb29
debo is my wide receiver 40. so
obviously
there is some viability to putting them
both in your lineup today now moving on
from that
let's get into sunday night football
carlos hyde who didn't play last week
we'll see about him tonight i don't
think it matters too much
maybe it just raises the expectations a
bit more for chris carson
if hyde is unable to play but not
somebody i really want in my lineup
even if he is active tonight against the
minnesota vikings moving on from sunday
night let's move on to
monday night football we're back to one
game on monday night football
mike williams up in the air with this
injury not somebody i would rely on as
much as i like justin herbert
i would probably shy away from using
mike williams against the new orleans
saints now
speaking of the scenes they could be
getting some players back this week
first of all
jared cook is listed as questionable
with the groin now
i don't have him inside my top ten he's
just outside that
you may just want to play it safe and
put somebody else in your lineup i
totally understand that
however should save a space for michael
thomas it certainly looks like he will
be back in the lineup
for the saints now put him in your flex
gives you more
legitimate flexibility there just in
case something happens and you have to
pivot to
latavius murray or a traequan something
like that even a justin jackson perhaps
but it looks like michael thomas will be
back if he's active obviously you want
to play him with confidence now
we go from the saints to the tuesday
night game that has a literally right
now and this could change in the next
couple of minutes
this game is still on the docket for
tuesday the buffalo bills john brown
listed his questionable up the calf
injury and
zach moss also listed as questionable so
not that you're playing loss that would
limit some of the excitement about devin
singletary
and obviously john brown's more in the
wide receiver three range because of how
well we've seen
stefan diggs adapt to buffalo so quickly
and
aj brown is listed as questionable for
the titans
could be his first week back in a little
while however like we said
we don't know if this game is going to
get played this could change in the next
10
15 minutes it could change the next 10
or 15 seconds i would not
bank as of right now on having your
titans
or your bills available on tuesday which
means you should be making
other plans and maybe a way to make
those other plans is right now
because i'm going to answer a bunch of
your questions from the br app so let's
get to those right now let's start here
uh ball is life is kenyon drake a
goodbye low
candidate or should i avoid altogether
somebody we covered in the week five
look ahead just because right now drake
and edmunds
are a few spots away from each other and
they're both outside the top 30. i don't
mind the idea of buying low on kenyon
drake i don't think chase edmonds is
going to go away
but because someone may be just over
kenyon drake for dealing with injuries
they're going to sell him on the cheap
that's fine but only
on the cheap because you are investing
in a good offense and he is a good
player
i simply can get it together all right
moving on from that backfield which has
been a little annoying
to this one with all the attention on
joshua kelly
is justin jackson flying under the radar
i think maybe potentially there another
backfield that we covered this week on
the week five look ahead
i think it is joshua kelly's backfield
as the lead but
nobody is replacing austin eckler justin
jackson to me
has some flex value where josh kelly has
now slotted himself into a very
comfortable
rb2 position in your fantasy lineup the
backfield questions
continue which backfield has been harder
to predict the rams or the ravens
so here's the funny thing i think the
rams we predicted
would be hard to predict daryl henderson
should have been the guy last week
it was malcolm brown cam makers is
active today we kind of knew that would
be a headache
baltimore what's going on here maybe
they haven't clicked right maybe they
haven't
snapped into focus the way you have
hoped with that offense lamar jackson's
been good not great
i think that's been more annoying
because we thought it would be mark
ingram and eventually garbage we saw him
in week one
so i'll say the ravens but both may
continue to be annoying
fantasy nightmares all right moving on
from that one uh jared mckinnon are
miles sanders in full ppr as we covered
in the
injuries it looks like mostly could be
back but regardless
if he's in or out later on you gotta
play miles sanders he's gonna continue
to eat up a bunch of touches
for the philadelphia eagles and their
absolutely ravaged
offense uh pretty much everywhere
especially in the skill position so fire
up miles sanders
he's a good player and the touches will
continue to come for him uh should i
start miles gaskin or
david johnson i'm gonna go david johnson
bill o'brien see you later
uh but it's closer than you know if he
asked me this couple weeks ago it's much
closer than i would have expected
a low end rb2 for david johnson a
low-end rb2 high-end rb3 for miles
gaskin
i will favor david johnson by just a
little bit all right there you go that
one's covered
do you like what you've seen out of
ronald jones so far this season he's
been fine
he should be better but this is ronald
jones i've never been a ronald jones
truther i know those people are out
there that go oh man ronald jones should
be the guy
i think he's gotten opportunities and
been fine with the opportunities he's
gotten
but no he does not impress me much next
uh who should i start jared cook or
dalton schultz look jared cook
is not a lot to play on monday night
football we know dalton schultz has been
getting it done
it's a safe play and it's a solid play i
have souls ranked tired by a few spots
get dalton schultz in your lineup and
he's taking on the giants
that's money let's go uh should i start
sammy walkers or rugs this week we know
rugs is in but i'm going to tell you
watkins in the same game taking on the
raiders
yes he can do this and then this and
then this and then this and then he goes
over there
you don't know what it's going to be
with watkins but he's healthier he's on
the better team
you're playing sammy watkins over rooks
next up michael gallup or christian kirk
oh the cowboys aren't they fun to deal
with when it comes to those wide
receivers
and yes kirk came back and scored that
touchdown i'm gonna lean gallop
i don't say either one of these names
with a lot of confidence because i think
these are also very like
much like sami watkins two players that
could be here and then go over here
and disappear and then come back when
you take them out of their lineup
they're
they're just those kind of guys all
right so we're going gallop but not with
a lot of confidence there
if the giants can't put up points
against the cowboy switch swiss
cheese defense is it time to bench danny
jones it's not on him
okay he lost barkley the wide receiver
core is messed up evan ingram i don't
think is the same player that it used to
be
it's not a very good team don't put this
on danny jones
i don't think it's worth benching him
not that you're playing him for fantasy
anyway
but no i don't put it on him i think
it's a tough time to figure out what you
have
in danny dimes because they're just such
a mess right now all right next up
which player is having a down year but
you're still buying everywhere
that you can is anybody you know buying
everywhere that i can
i mean kenyan drake on the cheap is fine
i was telling you to go get nixon last
week i'm still
on that for the most part um but there's
not a lot out there because i think
we're pretty much obvious with what's
going on in these offenses around the
nfl if you're getting the job done
through four or five weeks that'll
probably continue
maybe juju on the cheap because the
steelers are doing well i know deontay
johnson's there
that would be a name i i would possibly
consider next up there
uh let's see is brandon cooks droppable
in a 12-team league yeah
name value is that's the kind of guy
where name value and you're
you're attached to the past oh he did
nice job with the rams or the patriots
or
or the saints he's not that guy anymore
and desean watson is a very inconsistent
player he can be a superstar when he's
on
but when he's not it looks real ugly i
don't think you need to keep brandon
cooks around
don't let that name value keep him glued
to your team it's not worth it
uh chanult or slayton half point ppr
oh man chennault's probably safer but
slating against the cowboys is the
upside play so if you think safe you go
chanal
if you want to go with upside to go
slate i like both of these guys
i wish i could trust their quarterbacks
just a little bit more so there you go
uh kareem hunt will be the number one
wow this is a a statement from k-mania
karim will be the number one fantasy
running back while chubb is out agree or
disagree
i'm gonna disagree but not by much i
love the idea cream hunt look
he messed up off the field we know that
but before that happened
he was in that conversation of best
number one running back fast fantasy
running back and we had said this
if chubb went down the door was going to
be open for kareem hunt to step up and
be a league winner to be a
championship caliber fantasy running
back i'll say this
he's in that conversation will he be
number one i'm not quite sure because
they are using those other running backs
there so i can't say he's number one
but top five absolutely for kareem hunt
as long as nick chop is out believe me
i'm feeling that right now
how will the switch to kyle allen impact
washington football team skill position
players i think it helps
a little bit i don't think it's also
going to make taran mclauren a top 10
wide receiver for fantasy
but i do think it helps the offense he
did a nice job
i threw him in as a deep streamer a deep
sleepy a streamer last year a few times
so
i think it could happen again i think he
does make that offense better it just
hasn't happened for assets i wouldn't
mind if alex smith's ready
at some point for him to take that job
back over is damian harris
is it damian harris's job to lose in new
england it's anybody's job to lose new
england that could change as the wind
blows
we know they're not playing today but
that's the bellatrix
it's the hot hand it's rex it's james
white we've seen sony michelle
damien harris i don't think anybody has
a lock
on the top of the depth chart for the
new england patriot backfield
how crazy is it that despite his monday
night goose egg cavalry leader remains
wide receiver one and a half point ppr
yeah
he is that good and the falcons as a
team especially their defense are that
bad which means targets keep coming
and certainly julio jones i don't think
i'm saying anything crazy being on the
back end of this career
injuries really catching up to him he's
not playing today if you're just joining
us
i think all of this is leading to calvin
ridley uh
staying among top five maybe even top
three wide receivers he'll bounce back
today
after that goose egg last week uh austin
hooper and greg olson a half point ppr
oh i am sorry that you have to make this
decision
i'm gonna lead olson by just a little
bit i would hope you have better options
out there but if this is what you're
down to
i'll take that seattle offense it's
flying high maybe some red zone looks
for greg olson fire them up by the way
joku active today
going to be active for the browns so
throw that in there as well should i
flex justin jefferson or devonte parker
i'll give you some live rankings on this
one because i know i have it very close
uh parker for me is wide receiver 22
jefferson's 25.
that's two top 25 wide receivers in your
bench of one of them that tells me your
team's pretty good
i'll go parker by just a little bit all
right uh
got room for one more on the me cole
hardman bandwagon
what do you say camp hop on ah man i
really want to i do want to but
it just seems like they're pretty well
defined with tyree kill
and the ceh and kelsey i feel like if i
had him in a best bowl league i'd be so
happy
but i'll get him in my lineup one week
and he'll score and then i'll take him
out then you know it'll be that it'll be
i got him in the lineup in the wrong
week i love the player
it would be easier if he was higher up
on the depth chart if he met
more of the chiefs which is not a knock
on him it just tells you
how good the chiefs are all right next
one up what kind of productions should
we realistically expect from le'veon
bella's week look
the jets stink i would play jameson
crowder and pretty much nobody else with
confidence if you want to play bell
if he gives you rb2 numbers you should
be
jumping for joy the jets are awful
joe flacco is starting for them this
week i don't know what the heck they
think they're doing with adam gase
at best if you get your rv2 just just
thank the fantasy gods and then try to
trade them because i don't know what
else is going to happen with the jets it
can't get much worse
but probably can't it's the jets next up
here uh brandon nyuk or robbie anderson
oh robbie anderson regardless
but it looks like demo samuel we're
gonna see him out there later on today
so robbie anderson is getting the job
done kind of quietly is he one of the
more underrated players in fantasy just
because
he's not an exciting name the panthers
aren't anything special he's been
getting the job done i'll go robbie
anderson there on that one
all right next up greg ward or isaiah
ford yeah he's been making some waves as
well but i'm gonna go greg ward i think
there's opportunity there for him today
against the steelers
we know all the injuries there still no
jeffrey we know desean jackson's still
out obviously dallas got her on the ir
so yeah i'll go greg ward uh and
especially in ppr wide receiver four
exactly where a guy like sports should
be well tim patrick who we had on the
waiver wire weekly this week
uh put up the kind of numbers we hope to
get from cortland sutter
sutton moving forward no that's
expecting too much we know denver's
situation obviously they don't have
a game this week but i don't think the
situation's great enough i also don't
think tim patrick is at the skill level
of court and sudden he's got value he
doesn't have court and sutton value
unfortunately uh chase evans or de
ernest johnson and standard i'll go
edmonds by a little bit there
he's been getting a decent amount of
looks much to the chagrin of owners
of uh canyon drake we talked about that
earlier
i lead him a little bit more in standard
i think he's got more touchdown
viability
on the arizona cardinals all right fresh
off his three touchdown performance on
monday night football
oh i think i got this question last week
and i kind of crapped on robert tanyan
but is he the best tight end
in the league yes robert thompson is
clearly better than travis kelsey and
mark andrews and darren
waller he'd be better than tony gonzalez
and antonio gates put together right
touchdowns are random he's getting them
green bay is in a great spot okay so yes
he's better is he the best head in the
league come on now
we're not going that far but when you're
in a great situation
it's back to the point i made during
draft season good opportunities will be
there tonya is getting those on one of
the best offenses in football so he does
have viability he's not the best tight
end in football come on
next uh should i roll with teddy
bridgewater or
kurt cousins here you want to want live
rankings on this one
how exciting is this call kirk cause
it's at 14.
teddy bridgewater at nine against the
atlanta falcons teddy bridgewater is a
top
ten quarterback for this week yes i said
it that's how bad the falcons are
next up uh damir byrd led the patch with
10 targets last week
does he have flex appeal moving forward
yeah much like the backfield i feel like
the targets
in the passing game for the patriots are
kind of up for grabs now he could get
three next week when he's back
he could get 10 again but they don't
have that real lead guy
and hopefully cam is back next week but
you know edelman's the guy that you kind
of lean on
but i think he's got some viability
there because nobody
is really locking that top spot down
next up here should i start devos samuel
or jeff smith even samuel looking like
he's back i'm firing up this week with
debo samuel he's wide receiver 40 for me
so yes he's a flex play
and i'll play him over jeff smith next
up here what do we got biggest fantasy
disappointment of the season so far
the fact that we don't know when players
are gonna be out there
the fact that you know not everybody's
following the rules we're trying to get
a season in
that's the disappointment to me that we
get to a sunday morning
and literally don't know if a game is
going to happen
that's the biggest disappointment to me
is that the excitement of fantasy
football
has been overcome by everything that's
going on i know we're trying to get
through the season i'll throw that in
there
and i guess kenyon drake if you're
asking for a player but
just the inability to say that a game is
going to be played that's taking away
the excitement of fantasy this season
should i start crowder or renfro here
here's the one jet i'll tell you to play
play crowder joe flacco throwing on the
ball today against arizona
the target should be there whether they
get blown out or not
he's the only guy i feel pretty good
about for the new york jets that'll
probably come back to bite me because i
just suggested
a new york jet next up how would you
rank ertz
ebron and ingram this week well i know
that erch is on top of that list but let
me tell you how i have them i'll tell
you exactly what my rankings say because
they're sitting right in front of me
all right so we got arts then ingram
and then ibran in that order all inside
my top 12 this week so if you have all
three of those guys
you probably have a trade to make next
up here uh desperate times
call for desperate measures should i
replace russell gage
with uh katie i missed that name i
practiced that name too yeah you could
do that you can you can definitely do
that
um but i don't know if i'd be
running to go make a move like that uh i
think gage will stay in the mix a little
bit there but
i want to say this just so i say it
right because the man's name
is zacchaeus so i just want to make sure
i say that correctly
because i've been getting it wrong all
week long and i probably got it wrong
again next up
uh let's see here cooper cup or antonio
gibson standard scoring i'm playing cup
i still like the rams more gibson with
allen now playing quarterback for the
reds
for the washington football team man i'm
messing all the names up right now but
i'll go with cooper cup i trust the team
more
standard scoring hurts them you're
playing cooper cup over gibbs by at
least 10 spots at least in my rankings
t higgins or tui hilton standard i can't
believe it's a question
it's a fair question but i'm going to
play t.y hilton i don't
mind him today man a lot of injuries
there for the colts so we're going to
play him over t higgins although higgins
is certainly a name to watch and if he's
on your wave wire
scoop them up uh which quarterback
rookie quarterback has impressed you
more
joe burrow or justin herbert man how
about both of them
i mean bro came into the season knowing
he was going to be the guy i'm going to
pull up my rankings just to give you a
little piece of that for this week
burrow knew he was coming into the
season as the guy i have him at 15. i
have herbert at 16. i say herbert only
because
the numbers have been really good and he
got thrown into this job and has done a
really good job and they lost austin
eckler but both players
are looking real good they have
viability for fantasy this week included
and by the way rookie first round
quarterbacks they always play
coaches are full of it rookie
quarterbacks always play after draft in
the first round so it's close they're
both looking real good to me uh which
wide receiver will score more fantasy
points rest season juju or deontay i say
juju
by a little bit deante johnson has
clearly closed that gap that's a credit
to him
and maybe a little bit of a knock on
juju who's not the player he was a
couple of years ago
maybe he doesn't have antonio brown out
there and he's facing a little bit
stiffer competition when he lines up
that's part of it
but i'll say juju by just a little bit
they are very close one more
the most important question of the week
does jarvis landry
have a better arm than baker mayfield
he might i don't know for 35 times the
game but he might he might remember
baker's kind of in like the tony romo at
the end of his career phase
where they're running the ball well they
don't need him to do too much the team
is playing pretty well as a whole
good job by the browns so you don't need
baker to do too much you don't need to
launch balls down the field
you're running some fun plays with odell
you're getting landry working over the
middle cream hunts getting it done
any running back behind baker mayfield
seems to be getting it done right now so
it's not a knock on baker although i'll
say this as good as the browns have
looked it has hurt baker's fantasy value
because they don't ask him to do as much
so fantasy versus reality there
for baker mayfield all right your
questions have been answered
make sure you keep checking on the news
keep hitting that br app up
ask your questions there we'll see what
happens in these coven situations
i don't know if it'll get cleared up
anytime soon but let's all hope
stick with the players you know are
going to be out there that's the dumbest
fantasy advice but
honestly it's pretty logical right now
i'll be back with you next sunday right
here
on your fantasy fire drill for week
number six keep getting those questions
in on the brf
i'm matt camp this has been your fantasy
fire drill presented
by the miller like tantana good luck in
week five
[Music]
[Music]
you